This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in February of 2012, Miguel Ordinana went on a hike in Los Angeles' famous Griffith Park. The trail he took led him to a hill that looks out over the Hollywood Bowl and the Ford Amphitheater. It was one of my favorite spots to collect data from because I would get these really beautiful photos of animals because that is beautiful view of the sky and LA. Miguel is a wildlife biologist who studies animals inside the city of Los Angeles.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2012年2月，米格尔·奥尔迪纳纳在洛杉矶著名的格里菲斯公园徒步。他走的这条小路通往一座山丘，从那里可以俯瞰好莱坞露天剧场和福特圆形剧场。“这是我最喜欢收集数据的地点之一，因为我能拍到非常漂亮的动物照片，而且那里有绝佳的天空和洛杉矶视野。”米格尔是一位野生动物生物学家，专门研究洛杉矶市内的动物。
As a kid, he and his mom lived in a duplex in Los Felis on the south side of Griffith Park. That's producer Roxandra Guidi. On his hike, Miguel walked through canyons of dark green chaparral, collecting footage from a set of motion-activated trail cameras. He used the trail cams as part of his research for the U.S. Forest Service, monitoring the animals that called the park home. When he got back to his office, Miguel started sorting through the images. Usually what my brain kind of gets used to is it's like seeing a bunch of like empty photos because grass often triggers my camera or a bunch of deer and rabbit
小时候，他和母亲住在格里菲斯公园南侧洛斯费利斯的复式公寓里。那是制作人罗克桑德拉·吉迪。在徒步过程中，米格尔穿梭于深绿色的硬叶灌木峡谷中，从一组运动激活的红外相机中收集影像。他使用这些红外相机作为美国林务局研究的一部分，监测以该公园为家的动物。回到办公室后，米格尔开始整理这些照片。“通常我的大脑已经习惯了看到一堆空白照片，因为草经常会触发我的相机，或者是一堆鹿和兔子的照片。”
photos. Every now and then his cameras would pick up other animals too like coyotes. Maybe even a gray fox if I'm lucky because I just learned that gray foxes were in the park as well. But this time around, he didn't see any coyotes or foxes. Instead, he saw something even more extraordinary. All of a sudden I get this big puma butt on my computer screen and I'm just blown away.
偶尔，他的相机也会拍到其他动物，比如郊狼。“如果运气好的话，甚至可能有一只灰狐狸，因为我刚得知公园里也有灰狐狸。”但这一次，他没有看到任何郊狼或狐狸。相反，他看到了更非同寻常的东西。“突然间，我的电脑屏幕上出现了这样一个巨大的美洲狮屁屁，我整个人惊呆了。”
I literally jump out of my seat. A puma butt. I'm in shock and it's, I even go back a few photos and come back to it just to kind of refresh my eyes to make sure it's not a great day because often people will walk their dogs in front of my camera and that's a big animal. But this was obviously a puma, which is also commonly called a cougar or a mountain lion. It had a shiny coat of sandy brown fur, muscular legs, huge furry paws. And there's also even this little black marking, which is left by males as scent marking residue that only males produce. So not only did I
“我简直从座位上跳了起来。一个美洲狮的屁屁。我处于震惊之中，甚至往回看了几张照片，然后又切回来，好让眼睛清醒一下，确保这不是一只大狗——因为人们经常带着狗从我的相机前走过，那也是个大动物。”但这显然是一只美洲狮，通常也被称为美洲狮或山狮。它有着一层油亮沙棕色的皮毛、肌肉发达的腿、巨大的毛茸茸的爪子。甚至还有一个小黑斑，那是雄性留下来的气味标记残余，只有雄性才会产生。“所以不仅作为山狮我知道了，而且单凭这张屁屁照片，我们就可以确认它是一只雄性。”美洲狮被列为受特别保护的物种，算不上濒危但已接近。加利福尼亚州的山麓和山脉间大约有2000到6000只美洲狮。但这里居然有一只美洲狮，在一个每天有成千上万的人使用的市政公园里，
know as a mountain lion, but we would have confirmed that it was a male, just by this butt photo. Mountain lions are classified as a specially protected species, not quite endangered but close. There are somewhere between 2000 and 6,000 of them spread across the foothills and mountains of California. But here was a mountain lion, an municipal park that's used by thousands of people every day,
在全国最大、最拥挤的城市之一。这就像发现了大脚怪。这就像发现了哥斯拉或某种那样的都市传说。盯着电脑屏幕上美洲狮的屁屁，米格尔不禁纳闷：这只美洲狮到底是怎么落到这里的？它是从哪里来的？它是怎么到那里的？接下来会发生什么？这只美洲狮会怎么样？它会试图逃跑然后离开那里吗？这种情况很有可能会发生。在全州范围内，交通事故是美洲狮死亡的头号
in one of the largest, most congested cities in the country. This was like finding bigfoot. This was like finding, let you put gawdara or some sort of urban legend like that. As he stared at the Puma's butt on his computer screen, Miguel couldn't help but wonder, how on earth did this mountain line end up here where did he come from how did he get there what's going to happen next what's going to happen to this mountain line is he going to try and escape and get back off there was a good chance something like that could happen across the state traffic accidents are the leading
原因，然而不知何故，这只美洲狮奇迹般地在穿过洛杉矶最繁忙的高速公路的旅程中存活了下来。研究人员表示，这是有记录以来第一只深入城市核心区却没有被撞死的美洲狮，但现在它实际上被困住了，四周都被高速公路的海洋和拥挤的居民区所包围。野生动物和城市开发通常无法和谐共存。尤其是道路，割裂了广阔活动范围的动物的栖息地。这限制了它们的活动，使它们更难找到食物或配偶。然而，自从米格尔首次发现格里菲斯公园的美洲狮以来的几年里，
cost of mountain lion death and yet somehow this one had miraculously survived the track across LA's busiest highways. Researchers say it's the first documented case of a cougar making it this far into the urban core without getting run over and killed, but now he was effectively stuck, surrounded on all sides by an ocean of freeways and crowded neighborhoods. Wildlife and urban development don't usually go well together. Roads in particular fracture the habitats of wide-ranging animals. It restricts their movements and makes it harder for them to find food or a mate. However, in the years since Miguel first discovered Griffith Park's mountain
生物学家和城市规划师开始合作，制定计划试图帮助美洲狮在城市中更安全地移动。在这个过程中，这只猫科动物已经变成了某种名人，成为了一个重新设计我们的城市、让建筑环境对动物更友好的运动的象征。“嗨，嗨，嗨，嗨，动物们。”今年冬天，我在格里菲斯公园的边缘见到了米格尔。十年过去了，这只美洲狮依然把这里当作自己的家，而且它现在有了一个名字，
lion, biologists and urban planners have started working together, crafting a plan to try to help Puma's move more safely around the city. And in the process, this one cat has turned into something of a celebrity, the symbol of a movement to redesign our cities and make the built environment more friendly to animals. Hi, hi, hi, hi. animals. I met up with Miguel this past winter on the edge of Griffith Park. A decade later, the mountain lion still calls this place home, and he has a name now,
P-22。这名字很顺口，我喜欢。超级顺口。P-22代表22号美洲狮。这个名字是国家公园管理局给它的，在过去的20年里，该局一直在追踪南加州其他100多只美洲狮。就在米格尔发现它后不久，公园管理局就捕获了P-22，并为其佩戴了GPS项圈。通过追踪它的行踪，他们得以更好地了解它的健康状况、
P-22. It's catchy, I like it. Super catchy. P-22 stands for Puma No. 22. It was given to him by the National Park Service, which for the past 20 years has been tracking more than 100 other mountain lions across Southern California. Just after Miguel's discovery, the park service captured and tagged P-22 with a GPS collar. By following his movements, they've been able to get a better sense of his health, the
领地大小以及繁殖能力。“他们将它的基因与他们研究过的一只雄性进行了匹配，那是它的父亲P1，也就是Puma 1的缩写，它是国家公园管理局研究的第一只美洲狮。它是一个凶猛的个体，体型是最大的之一。”多年来，P22的父亲P1一直是圣莫尼卡山脉占统治地位的雄性美洲狮。它与在其领地内游荡的雌性美洲狮交配并生下了一窝窝幼崽。但当它找不到配偶时，它开始与自己的后代交配。低遗传多样性是圣莫尼卡山脉所有美洲狮都面临的问题。
size of his territory and his ability to reproduce. They did matches genetics with a male that they studied, who is his dad, P1, which is dance for Puma 1, and he was the first Puma ever studied by the National Park Service. And he was a vicious individual like the big one of the biggest. For years, P22's dad, P1, was the dominant male cougar in the Santa Monica Mountains. He fathered litters of cubs with the female mountain lions who roamed his territory. But when he couldn't find a mate, he started mating with his offspring. Load genetic diversity is a problem among all mountain lions in the Santa Monica Mountains.
P1也是极具领地意识的。当它的幼崽开始占据它的很多空间时，它开始杀死自己的后代。P22可能正是通过进行这趟不可思议的迁徙来到格里菲斯公园，才在父亲的暴怒下幸存下来的。“所以，我基本上知道它最喜欢的藏身处和路线，也就是小径、漏斗形通道、峡谷、十字路口和小径。拜托，当你看到粪便、足迹或其他被称为刮痕的迹象时——
P1 was also fiercely territorial. When his cubs started taking up a lot of his space, he started killing his offspring. It's possible that P22 survived his father's wrath by making this unlikely journey to Griffith Park. So, I know basically it's favorite. Hangouts and pots, which are trails, funnels, canyons, intersections and trails. Please, when you see scat tracks or these other signs called scrapes
它们喜欢用后脚像这样向后踢出痕迹——我们可能在那里会看到一些。”米格尔用脚轻轻踢起泥土，好让我试着想象这些刮痕。现在我在小径上寻找美洲狮的痕迹，检查地面上有没有粪便。我内心深处有一部分很想见到P22，但更大一部分却不想。
where they like kick through the back feet like this, we might see some up there. Miguel is kicking up the dirt gently with his feet so I can try to picture these scrapes. And now I'm looking for signs of a cougar on our trail, checking the ground for Scott. There's a part of me that wants to see P22, but a bigger part does not.
它与环境融为一体，那么安静无声。“对啊。”以至于它可能就在旁边。但即使它真的就在旁边，它也很有可能会隐藏在公园幽深的峡谷和洞穴中。在我们的想象中，美洲狮可能显得凶猛，但现实中它们其实相当胆小。它们不像豹子、非洲狮和美洲虎那样的大型猫科动物。
He blends in so well, so quiet and silent. Yeah. That he just can be right over there. But even if he is right over there, he's likely to stay hidden in the park's deep canyons and caves. Mountain lions may come off us ferocious in our imaginations, but in reality they're actually pretty timid. They're not like the big cast like leopards and African lions and jaguars.
它们稍微更大胆、更凶猛一些。它们有点像你的猫，基本上有点像保安猫。在过去十年里，没有任何证据表明有其他美洲狮进入P22的领地，部分原因是因为它们也必须在从圣莫尼卡山脉出发、穿过405号州际公路和101号高速公路的危险旅程中存活下来。但也因为格里菲斯公园很小，雄性美洲狮的典型活动范围是150平方英里，但P22只有9平方英里的活动空间。这是个问题，因为如果P-22想找个配偶，它就必须原路返回，
They're a little bit more bold and fierce. They're a little bit like your cat that is a little bit like a security cat basically. In the last decade, there's been no evidence of other mountain lions coming into P22's territory, partly because they too would have to survive the treacherous journey from the Santa Monica Mountains across Interstate 405 and Highway 101. But also because Griffith Park is small, the typical range of a male mountain lion is 150 square miles, but P22 has only nine square miles to work with. And that's a problem, because if P-22 wants to find a mate, he'd have to retrace his steps,
面对繁忙的高速公路和居民区，或者闯入另一只美洲狮的领地。“你知道它是否曾试图离开公园回到圣莫尼卡山脉吗？”“没有，但它……好吧，我不知道它当时是怎么想的，但有一次它竟然穿过了巴勒姆大道，那条路与环球影城相邻。那是环球影城。显然有人看到P22真的在过马路并报告了。不管怎样，它确实穿过去了。当时实际上在后台外景地，就是他们做有轨电车观光等等的地方，并在那里过了一夜，结果它可能并不喜欢那次经历，
facing busy freeways and neighborhoods or stepping into another cubers territory. Do you know if he's attempted to leave the park and go back to the Santa Monica Mountains? No, but he... well, I don't know what he was thinking, but one time he actually crossed Barham Boulevard, which is ordering us with universal. That's universal studios. Apparently someone so P-22 literally crossing the street and reported it. But anyway, he crossed over it. When actually in the bath lot, when they do the tram tours and all that, and spent the night, and didn't like what he experienced,
于是它马上又穿了回来，之后就再也没离开过。”“哇。”P22其实已经离开过格里菲斯公园好几次了。人们曾发现它在好莱坞山以及公园周围的一些富人区游荡。事实上，它已经成了某种当地的名人。天使之城的居民喜欢追踪它的行踪。
that he crossed right back, and he hasn't left every single. Wow. P22 has actually left Griffith Park a number of times. He's been spotted roaming around the Hollywood Hills and some other well-to-do neighborhoods surrounding the park. In fact, he's become something of a local celebrity. Angelina knows love to track his whereabouts.
附近的居民很喜欢听到关于P22的目击报告，并认为它可能是因为天气热才冒险走出格里菲斯公园的。“我发现它在喝喷头漏到人行道上的水。”追踪和研究P——甚至连Stitcher自己的内容副总裁、我们节目的老板科林·安德森，也有过一次与洛杉矶最受欢迎的美洲狮狭路相逢的经历。“我抬头一看，P22离我只有大约10英尺远，”
Nearby residents like hearing about sightings of P-22 and believe he may have ventured out of Griff the park because of the heat. I found him drinking from a sprinkler head that was kind of dripping down onto the sidewalk. Experts who track and study P- Even Stitcher's own VP of content and our show's boss, Colin Anderson, had his own one-in with LA's favorite mountain lion. I looked up and P22 was about 10 feet away from me
“而我当时非常清楚的一点是，我穿着凉鞋。当时我想：这可不太妙。我的短裤和凉鞋，完全不是为了与美洲狮对抗而穿的装扮。”尽管如此，在经历了一番探险之后，P-22总是会回到格里菲斯公园。从格里菲斯公园的山峰之一（约1600英尺高）望去，
and one thing I was really aware of was that I was wearing sandals. And I was like, this isn't optimal. My shorts and my sandals, like, not dressed for a mountain lion confrontation. Still, at the end of his adventures, P-22 always ends up coming back to Griffith Park. From one of the peaks in Griffith Park, about 1,600 feet,
你可以将周围的土地尽收眼底。向南是洛斯费利斯和银湖社区，远处是优雅的棕榈树；向东是洛杉矶河的混凝土河道，它沿着加州最繁忙的高速公路之一——5号州际公路延伸。向北和向西是著名的好莱坞标志，以及另一条一直延伸到海岸的高速公路101国道。从这里向上望去，你可以看到P-22确实被困在这座孤岛上了。但情况并非一直如此。格里菲斯公园的山丘是
you can get a lay of the surrounding land. To the south, the Los Felis and Silver Lake neighborhoods with sleek palm trees in the distance, to the east is the concrete channel of the LA River, which runs along Interstate 5, one of the busiest freeways in California. Into the north and west is the famous Hollywood sign, and another highway, the 101, which runs all the way out to the coast. From up here, you can see that P-22 really is marooned on this island. But it wasn't always like that. The hills of Griffith Park are part of the
圣莫尼卡山脉的一部分。只是一项项开发和主要道路吞噬了大片土地。“人们把建设推向绝对极限，然后再考虑野生动物，才去考虑后期的影响。”这种岛屿效应并不是什么自然现象。它是几十年间做出的一系列决策的结果。最近的一项研究发现，如果城市开发
Santa Monica mountain range. It's just that developments and major roadways have chewed up large swaths of land. People build to absolute maximum and then think about wildlife, think about the repercussions later. The island effect isn't some natural occurrence. It's the result of a series of decisions made over decades. A recent study found that if urban development
继续下去，南加州的狮子可能会在未来50年内消失。这样一个重要的顶级掠食者的消亡，将对整个生态系统产生连锁反应。“对我来说，P-22就像对许多人一样，不仅是在社会观念上改变了我的思考方式，在科学上也同样如此。”
continues as it has, mountain lions could disappear in Southern California within the next 50 years. The demise of such an important apex predator would have a downstream effect on the entire ecosystem. For me, P-22, like for a lot of people, was an entry into not just socially changing my thinking, but scientifically.
“就好像我真的没有接触过连通性科学。”贝丝·普拉特是国家野生动物联合会加州区域执行主任。她是P-22的超级粉丝。她的肩膀上甚至纹着美洲狮的脸。就在P-22被发现前后，贝丝来到洛杉矶为她的书《当美洲狮是邻居》搜集资料。她遇到了国家公园管理局的一位美洲狮专家，后者带着她在城里到处转。
Like, I just had really not been exposed to the science of connectivity. Beth Pratt is the California Regional Executive Director for the National Wildlife Federation. She's a big fan of P-22. He even has a tattoo of the Mountain Lions face on her shoulder. Around the time P-22 was discovered, Beth came to LA to research her book when mountain lions are neighbors. She met up with a Puma expert from the National Park Service who took her around town.
“我们开车在圣莫尼卡山脉转悠，他指着这些高速公路，谈论着生活在那里的其他猫科动物。当时我就想：哇，你知道的，这可能是一个……这也让我觉得这个问题是可以解决的。”贝丝认为一定有一种方法可以重新缝合这片景观，确保没有其他美洲狮为了四处游荡和寻找配偶而不得不穿过多条高速公路。她与其他野生动物专家谈论过这个问题，但没有人有具体的解决方案。
We drove around the Santa Monica Mountains and he's pointing out these freeways and talking about the other cats that live there. And I was like, wow, this is, you know, this is a probably like, and it also kind of me this is fixable. Beth thought there must be a way to restitch the landscape to make sure no other mountain land would have to cross multiple freeways in order to roam and find a mate. She spoke with other wildlife experts about the problem, but no one had a concrete solution.
“我知道它们需要一些东西来帮助实现连通。是一个隧道吗？是围栏吗？是一个天桥吗？”贝丝和她的同事们并不打算一下子把庞大的南加州变成一个安全的美洲狮栖息地，但他们总得从某处开始。于是她联合了当地的野生动物组织，
I knew they needed something to help with connectivity. Was it a tunnel? Was it sensing? Was it an overpass? Beth and her colleagues weren't going to turn sprawling Southern California into a safe mountain lion habitat, all at once, but they needed to start somewhere. So she joined forces without a local wildlife organizations
发起了一场名为“拯救洛杉矶美洲狮”的运动。该组织计划提高人们的意识，并对当地美洲狮种群进行更多研究，但他们的主要目标是建造一座巨大的、同类中首创的城市野生动物通道。野生动物通道是帮助动物安全越过公路等人造屏障的实体结构。通常，它们建在道路穿过茂密森林和其他开阔土地的地方。
and launched a campaign called Save a Lake Uggers. The group planned to race awareness and do more research on the local mountain line population, but their main goal was to build a massive. First of its kind, urban wildlife crossing. Wildlife crossings are physical structures that help animals safely navigate human-made barriers like highways. Often, they're both in places where roadways cut through dense forests and
事实证明，这些通道既能减少动物与车辆的碰撞，又能重新连接不同物种赖以生存的家园。它们通常以地下通道或天桥的形式出现，在欧洲已经使用了几十年。最近，它们开始在北美兴起。在加拿大的班夫国家公园，一个野生动物通道网络每天都被熊、狼、驼鹿、麋鹿以及美洲狮使用，这证明了在物种倾向于迁徙的地方精心设计通道可以让人类和野生动物受益。然而，像洛杉矶这样的大都市里建设野生动物天桥还是破天荒头一遭。
other open land. Crossings have been shown to both reduce animal vehicle crashes and relink territories that different species call home. They typically come in the form of an underpass or an overpass and have been used widely in Europe for decades. More recently, they've started taking off in North America, in Canada's Banff National Park, a network of wildlife crossings are used every day by bears, wolves, mues, elk, and, yes, mountain lions, proving that a thoughtfully designed crossing in places where species tend to migrate can benefit humans and wildlife. However, a wildlife overpass in a megacity like Los Angeles had never been done before.
政客们尤其持怀疑态度，不仅对城市野生动物通道的实用性存疑，对其价格标签也是如此。这将是世界上最大、最昂贵的通道，横跨10条高速公路车道。加州交通局过去曾三次为这样的项目争取联邦资金，但都失败了。最初，甚至连贝丝也很难将野生动物通道的想法推销给她的上级。
Politicians in particular were skeptical, not just about the utility of an urban wildlife crossing, but its price tag. This would be the biggest and most expensive crossing in the world, spanning 10 lanes of highway. The California Department of Transportation had tried to get federal funding for a project like this three times in the past and failed. Initially, even Beth struggled to sell the idea
“我刚开始做这个项目时有个老板，我向他做演示，他们问：‘什么是野生动物通道？那有什么用？这怎么能规模化？’” “拯救洛杉矶美洲狮”运动需要让人们更容易接受他们的项目。他们需要帮助人们理解城市内部野生动物保护的重要性，为天使之城的居民提供支持该通道的清晰理由。他们需要P-22。
of a wildlife crossing to her higher ups. I had a boss when I started it, who I presented, and they were like, what's a wildlife crossing? What does that do? How is that scalable? The Save-A-Lake Hoogers campaign needed to make it easier for people to get on board with their project. They needed to help people understand the importance of wildlife conservation inside the
听着，这不是偶然。你知道，这是洛杉矶。洛杉矶热爱名流并崇拜他们。而这里正好有这样一只猫，它居然住在好莱坞标志下面。它长得很帅。它呢，你知道的，在约会生活上遇到了挑战。这是一个为好莱坞电影量身定制的故事。自从它被发现以来，天使之城的居民们逐渐了解了P22。随着每一次擦肩而过，它不再是一只在格里菲斯公园四处游荡的可怕美洲狮，而更像是一个邻居。一个你在倒垃圾或清晨散步时可能会碰到的熟人。
city itself, to give Angelinos a clear reason to support the crossing. They needed P-22. Listen, it's no accident. You know, this is LA. And LA loves their celebrities and worships them. And here's this cat that literally lives under the Hollywood sign. He's handsome. He's, you know, challenged with his dating life. It is a made for Hollywood movie. Since his discovery, Angelinos have gotten to know P22, with every passing encounter, he was less a fearsome mountain lion prowling Griffith Park, and more of a neighbor. Someone you might run into as you take out your trash or go out in a morning walk.
“拯救洛杉矶美洲狮”利用这种认知让人们关心起这座通道。这场运动还围绕P-22构建了一个叙事。它是一只独自闯荡的年轻幼崽，靠着某种运气在穿过两条主要高速公路后存活了下来。然后它落脚在洛杉矶最著名的公园里，自己也成了名人。只是现在它被孤立了，甚至孤身一人，需要找到一条返回的出路。这是一个人们能与之共鸣的故事，许多人也确实做到了。它的故事就是能引起共鸣，比任何其他动物都强。没有哪个故事能比这个更大。
Save LA Cougars used that recognition to get people to care about the crossing. The campaign also helped build a narrative around P22. He was the young cub struck out on his own and by some stroke of luck survived crossing two major highways. He then landed in Los Angeles' most famous park where he himself became famous. Except now he was isolated, alone even, needing to find a way back out. It was a story people could connect to, and many did. His story just resonates, compared to any other animals. No other story is bigger than this one.
从2016年开始，“拯救洛杉矶美洲狮”运动在格里菲斯公园组织了一个名为“P-22日”的全天候节日。在那里，天使之城的居民可以报名参加沿P-22长达40英里的徒步路线进行的小组徒步。参加节日的人甚至可以购买P-22的周边商品，比如T恤或手提袋。最重要的是，他们可以为野生动物通道捐款。该运动就在上个月举办了他们最近的一场活动。“我喜欢P-22的一点是，它反映了在洛杉矶城市化地区寻找伴侣的挣扎，我觉得我也面临着同样的挣扎。”“P-22，P-22，P-22，P-22，P-22……”最初，贝丝对这一切感到有点奇怪。
Starting in 2016, the Saebele Cougars campaign organized an all day festival in Griffith Park called P22 Day. There, Angelinos can sign up for group hikes along parts of P22's 40-mile trek. Festival goers can even buy P22 swag like a 1C or a tow bag. And most importantly, they can donate to the wildlife crossing. The campaign held their most recent event just last month. What I love about Pete 22 is that he reflects the struggles of finding a mate in the urbanized area of Los Angeles, which I feel like I face the same struggles. Pete 22, Pete 22, Pete 22, Pete 22, Pete 22, Pete, Pete, Pete. Initially, Beth felt a little strange about all of this.
她和她的运动成功让人们关心起洛杉矶的美洲狮，但吸引人们的并不是科学。而是P-22的名气。这场运动将P-22拟人化了，这是科学家通常极力避免的事情。“听着，有人讨厌我对这场运动的方法。我讨厌拟人化。甚至我组织里的人也觉得……我这是在对某些传统科学家行异端邪说。”我对这一点很好奇。这是否部分类似于一种老派观念？就好像：你不需要拟人化或讲故事？我们就应该严格遵循科学，并希望资金能到位？
She and her campaign succeeded in making people care about a lace mountain lion, but it wasn't a science that brought them in. It was P-22 celebrity. The campaign was anthropomorphizing P-22, which is something that scientists usually try to steer clear of. Listen, there are people who hate my approach to the campaign. I hate ants or more. Even people in my own organization, like I'm committing heresy with some of these, you know, traditional scientists. I'm really curious about that. Is that part of kind of a
所以我想有很多人只是在那种极度硬核科学的模式中受过教育，他们很难接受拟人化。但把一只美洲狮变成一个角色已经取得了成效。建设野生动物通道的运动
just like an old school? Like you do not need to, yeah, more fives or like tell me a story. Like we should strictly follow follow the science and hope that the funding comes through. So I think there's just a lot of people who are just educated in that very hard science mode and they have a hard time with Andrew Morpheizing. But turning a Puma into a character has gotten results. The campaign to build the wildlife crossing
已经从基金会和私人捐赠中筹集了超过1.05亿美元。很大一部分要归功于P-22的故事。整个事件的成功超出了贝丝和她同事们最疯狂的想象。“我们想欢迎所有观看直播的人来到华莱士和安娜堡野生动物通道的奠基仪式！呜呼！”这项通道的工程实际上在今年早些时候就已经开始了。
has raised more than $105 million from foundations and private donations. A lot of it on the back of B-22's story. The whole thing has been a success beyond Beth and her colleagues' wildest imaginations. And we want to welcome everybody watching to the groundbreaking for the Wallace, Annaburg, wildlife crossing. Woohoo! The work on the crossing actually began earlier this year.
贝丝在101号高速公路上方的一处地点的演讲中发言，P-22在前往格里菲斯公园的路上可能自己就穿过了这个区域。“我们非常荣幸能来到这里，与你们所有人一同庆祝。你们曾看着这个不可能实现的梦想，像我一样说：‘绝不在我的眼皮底下发生。’我们绝不会眼睁睁地看着这个美洲狮种群在我们的眼皮底下灭绝。”她演讲的背景时刻提醒着人们美洲狮所面对的是什么：川流不息的汽车和卡车，这条高速公路本身与圣莫尼卡山脉平行，
Beth spoke from the site above a section of the 101 Freeway, an area that P-22 may have crossed himself on his way to Griffith Park. And we are so honored to be here and celebrating with you all, who looked at this impossible dream and like me said not on my watch We are not gonna let this mountain line population go extinct on our watch The backdrop of her speech was a reminder of just what a mountain line is up against a non-stop stream of cars and trucks the highway itself runs parallel to the Santa Monica Mountains,
将其与北部的西米山脉以及更大的洛帕德雷斯国家森林隔开。这一段道路是美洲狮想要寻找更多配偶和更多土地时的最大障碍。正因为该通道位于一个大都市内，设计师和景观建筑师们肩负重任，必须精心设计以鼓励动物们尝试使用这座桥梁。团队正在与专家们进行讨论，涉及
separating it from the Seamy Hills and the larger Los Badgers National Forest of the North. The stretch of road is the biggest obstacle for mountain lions who want to find more mates and more land. And because the crossing is in a major city, designers and landscape architects have their work cut out for them to encourage animals to give the bridge a try. The team is talking to experts on
光污染、真菌、生态修复、围栏甚至声音设计。建成后，它将长210英尺，宽175英尺。“所以，是的，有很多技术。我们知道如何模拟栖息地并将它们吸引到那里。你知道，我们的通道之所以这么宽的原因之一，是为了让动物们觉得它们不在高速公路上。所以你不能只建一个……我们经常被问到：‘为什么不能只建4英尺宽来省钱呢？’好吧，可能会有一两只动物使用它，但你需要它看起来就像自然景观。所以每有一英尺长，就得有一个比例，它必须相应地变得更宽。”
light pollution, fungi, ecological restoration, fencing, and even sound design. When it's done, it'll be 210 feet long and 175 feet wide. So yeah, there's a lot of technique. We know how to mimic the habitat and attract them there. You know, one of the reasons ours is so wide is you're getting up to make the animals feel like they're not on the highway. So you can't just put like a we get asked why can't you just do four feet and save money. Well, a couple animals might use it, but you need it to look like the landscape. So like for every foot long, there's a ratio. It has to be, you know, that much more wide.
一旦有几只动物查看了这个通道并发现它确实管用，更多的动物就会随之而来。消息在动物世界里真的一传十、十传百。几周前，我前往通道的选址地去感受一下那里的景观。“所以这就是未来位于阿古拉山（Agoura Hills）的自由峡谷野生动物通道的选址。这其实是卡戴珊家族著名的社区。我不知道是哪个卡戴珊，但也许是金或凯莉。
And once a few animals check out the crossing and see that it works, more of them will follow. Word literally gets out in the animal world. A few weeks back, I went out to the site of the crossing to get a feel for the landscape. So this is the site of the future Liberty Canyon Wildlife Crossing in aora Hills. This is actually the famous neighborhood of the Kardashians. I don't know which Kardashians but maybe Kim
我只知道这两个。”我猜错了。卡戴珊家族住在东边大约15分钟车程的地方。但无论如何，你明白我的意思。这里有很大的开阔空间。你可以看到圣莫尼卡山脉。这里景色美极了。我请卡特·苏佩菲斯基（Kat Superfisky）和我一起去这个通道的建设工地。她说她的姓氏很好听、很有趣。她也是一名设计师和教育工作者，
Kylie. Those are the only two I know. I was wrong. The Kardashians live about 15 minutes east from here. But anyway you you get the idea. This is, there's a lot of open space. You can see the Santa Monica Mountains. It's gorgeous out here. I asked Kat Superfisky to join me at the construction site for this crossing. She says, cool as her last name is fun to say. She's also a designer and educator
是洛杉矶市的第一位城市生态学家。我们正沿着一条深沟徒步，这条深沟从工地边缘开始，一直延伸到山上。这是未来那座桥的一端。野生动物本来就会在这里穿过，并且通常会遇到飞驰的汽车。“即使从我们现在站的这个地方，你也能看到清晰的连接。我们正站在一种山脉区域。我们正俯瞰着另一个。如果你是一只动物，你会想要连接
in the city of LA's first urban ecologist. We're hiking past a deep trench that starts at the edge of the site and creeps up the hill. This is one end of that future bridge. An area where wild animals are known to cross anyway and where they would typically run into fast-moving cars. Even from where we're standing right here, you see the clear linkage. We're standing on one kind of mountain, mountainous area. We're looking down to another one. If you're an animal, you're gonna want to connect
到另一个山坡。所以它们会再次来到101号高速公路，除了穿过去到达另一边之外，它们别无选择。而现在，我们为它们提供了非常具有挑战性的条件来横穿那条公路，就像在玩《青蛙过河》游戏一样。所以把这看作某种漏斗是个不错的视角。”“确实如此，没错。这就是为什么选择这个地点。”“完全正确。是的，当国家公园……P-22和卡特大约在同一时间来到这座城市。而在那时，她根本没有意识到人类与自然共存的可能性，
to that other, the hill sides. And so they would, again, make it up to the 101 freeway and then they would have no option other than to cross it to get to the other side. And right now we're providing pretty challenging conditions for them to have across that like Frogger. So it's good to think of this as a funnel of sorts. Yep, really. And that's why this site was chosen. Exactly. Yeah, when the National Park P-22 and Cat arrived in the city around the same time. And back then, she just wasn't aware of the possibilities of humans coexisting with nature,
与野生动物在洛杉矶这样的地方共存的可能性。“我来的时候以为洛杉矶不会有很多自然风光，而且我将从混凝土本身开始起步。所以，你知道的，我花了好几年时间才真正改变我看待洛杉矶这样地方的方式，我做了大量练习，剥离混凝土
with wildlife in a place like Los Angeles. I showed up thinking that there wasn't gonna be a lot of nature in LA, and that I was gonna be starting kind of from, you know, the concrete itself. And so, you know, it took me a couple years to really change the way that I saw a place like LA and I practiced a lot, peeling back the concrete
、钢铁和基础设施，眯起眼睛凝视着周围的风景，然后说：‘好吧，我实际上还是能某种程度上看到山脉。地形和地貌依然存在。’”这一切之中存在着巨大的讽刺。尽管付出了所有的努力，我们还是无法知道P-22是否真的会使用这座桥。阿古拉山距离格里菲斯公园向西约25英里。
and the steel and infrastructure and kind of crossing my eyes and staring at the landscape around me and saying, okay, I can still actually kind of see the mountains. The topography in the landform is still there. There is a great irony in all this. Despite all the effort, we have no way of knowing whether P-22 will actually use this bridge. The Agora Hills are about 25 miles west of Griffith Park.
科学家说，作为一只年迈的美洲狮，它很可能会采取安全策略，原地待命，接受自己永远单身的命运。但我们确实知道，许多许多其他动物会使用这个通道。狐狸、山猫、鹿，以及其他寻找伴侣或寻找更多属于自己的空间的野生动物。贝丝和米格尔都承认，他们利用P-22来尝试做一件更大的事情：开始将洛杉矶破碎的栖息地重新缝合在一起，让天使之城的居民开始将他们的城市视为一个生态系统。如今，不仅是科学家和环保主义者想要谈论P-22。一位母亲告诉我，她的儿子认为P-22是个超级英雄，
Scientists say that as an older Puma, he's likely to play it safe, stay put, and accept his fate as a forever bachelor. But we do know that many, many other animals will use that crossing. Foxes, Bobcat, Steer, and other mountain lions looking to find a mater, more space to call their own. Beth and Miguel both acknowledged that they used P-22 to try to do something bigger, to begin to stitch the fragmented habitat of Los Angeles back together, to get Angelinos to start thinking of their city as an ecosystem. In these days, it's not just scientists and environmentalists who want to talk about P-22. One mother told me her son thinks P22 is a superhero,
他在屋里跑来跑去，披着斗篷说：‘我是P-22，我要去……’就像那种根本上的联系，它较少关乎科学，却让我充满希望，因为我认为洛杉矶的孩子们尤其如此，他们了解这些猫科动物就像了解美式足球运动员一样。”据我们所知，P-22正在它的市政公园里过着卑微且相对快乐的美洲狮生活。
and he runs around the house with a cape and saying, you know, I'm P22, and I'm going to say, like, it's that fundamental connection that is less about science that I am hopeful about, because I think LA kids especially, they know these cats like they know football players. For all we know, P-22 is living a humble and relatively happy mountain lion life in his municipal park.
但在不知不觉中，它让我们在一些重要的事情上达成了一致，不仅是需要在洛杉矶建造一座巨大的野生动物通道，更是对共存和连通性的需求。这样，在像洛杉矶这样的大城市里，你、我、P-22以及所有其他生活在城市的野生动物，都能感到不那么孤独。广告之后，一个付诸行动的野生动物通道。好的，我回到了我们的制作人罗克桑德拉·吉迪身边。罗克桑，关于这些野生动物通道，你还有一件事想跟我们分享。
But unknowingly, he's got us on the same page about something important, not just the need to build a huge wildlife crossing in Los Angeles, but the need for coexistence, for connectivity. So that in a big city like LA, you, me, P-22, and all the other urban dwelling wild animals can all feel a little less alone. When we come back, a wildlife crossing in action. All right, I'm back with our producer, Rook Sandrick Weedy. Rooks, you have one more thing that you want to share with us about these wildlife crossings. Yeah, I have one more quick and kind of a silly thing, except I know I'm not the only one who
是的，我还有一个简短且有点滑稽的事情，不过我知道我不是唯一一个对此着迷的人。所以我要让你打开这段剪辑和我一起看。它真的很短。所以我们直接播放整个片段吧。好的，所以这是一只郊狼跳过一条隧道，它似乎在和一只獾玩耍，试图让獾跟着它进隧道。这是我看到的吗？
geeks out on this stuff. So I'm going to have you open up this clip and watch it with me. It's really short. So we'll just play the whole clip. Okay, so it's a coyote jumping through a tunnel, and it seems to be playing with a badger and trying to get it to follow it down the tunnel. Is that what I've seen? Exactly. It's like these two buddies are meeting up by the end of the tunnel and I just love how excited that Coyote is.
完全正确。就像这两个好朋友在隧道尽头碰面一样，我太喜欢那只郊狼兴奋的样子了。它看起来就像一只狗，在某处发现了它的牵引绳，然后准备好去散步一样。完全是这样。这太棒了。那么这个片段里到底发生了什么？
He looks just like a dog when he spots his leash somewhere and he's ready to go for a walk. Totally, totally. This is so great. So what is going on in this clip? Well, it went viral about two years ago. And what I love about it is that the tunnel they are merrily strolling through, it's actually a wide life crossing. Oh, okay. Yeah. Yeah.
嗯，大约两年前它在网上疯传了。我喜欢的是，它们欢快漫步穿过的那个隧道，实际上就是一个野生动物通道。哦，原来如此。对的。
Yeah. This one specifically is a wide life underpass. And it's in California further up the 101 up near Gilroy, a few miles south of San Jose. And this is the same one of one that runs through LA and is a big problem for, you know, for mountain lions in the area that we were talking about in the story. Yeah, exactly. So this underpass was built to seemingly
是的。这个具体是一个野生动物地下通道。它位于加利福尼亚州，沿着101号公路往上走，靠近吉尔罗伊（Gilroy），在圣何塞以南几英里处。这就是穿过洛杉矶的那条101号公路的同一段，它正是我们刚才在故事中讨论的该地区美洲狮的一个大问题。没错，正是如此。所以修建这个地下通道，显然是为了
help with that habitat fracturing and to prevent road kill, not to mention all the accidents and deaths that vehicle animal collisions create, you know. Which is not a small number. No, not at all. Research shows that there are between one and two million Vehicle and large animal collisions every year in the US and Thousands of those accidents result in some sort of human injury and sometimes even in human deaths
帮助解决栖息地割裂问题，并防止道路杀戮，更不用说动物与车辆碰撞所造成的所有事故和死亡了。这不是一个小数字。不，一点也不。研究表明，美国每年发生100万到200万起汽车与大型动物的碰撞事故，数千起此类事故导致某种形式的人员受伤，有时甚至导致人员死亡。
Yeah, and almost always the death of the of the animal too. Oh, yeah, definitely So what we're seeing in this video of the animal too. Oh yeah, definitely. So what we're seeing in this video with this underpass and this coyote and this badger, is this typical behavior for these two or is the underpass like causing them to behave differently or what is going on?
是的，而且几乎总是伴随着动物的死亡。哦，是的，绝对如此。所以我们在视频中看到的这个地下通道、这只郊狼和这只獾，这是这俩的典型行为吗？还是说地下通道导致它们的行为发生了变化？这到底是怎么回事？
You know, that's a great question. Coyotes and badgers were not widely known to hunt together until kind of recently, and this video shows that dynamic because a coyote can chase and catch its prey and a badger can dig if the prey heads underground. So the video helps show scientists this collaboration among species. So it's like, you know, they're doing what they normally do. They just happen to be doing it while crossing under the one on one.
你知道，这真是个好问题。直到最近，人们才知道郊狼和獾会一起狩猎，而这段视频展现了这种动态，因为郊狼可以追捕并抓住猎物，而如果猎物钻进地下，獾则可以进行挖掘。因此，视频有助于向科学家展示物种之间的这种合作。所以这就好像，你知道的，它们在做它们平时做的事。它们只是刚好在穿过101号公路下方时做了这件事。
That's right. Exactly. If anything, the underpass facilitated them to go on and do the thing that they do. And you know, there's a lot of videos out there documenting animals using a crossing. There's this video of a Florida panther and it's kittens going under an interstate in Florida
没错。完全正确。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是地下通道为它们继续做它们一直在做的事情提供了便利。你知道，有很多视频记录了动物使用通道的情景。有这样一段视频：一只佛罗里达黑豹和它的幼崽穿过佛罗里达州的一条州际公路，
and a bobcat and her kittens sort of excitedly prancing under a bridge in Salinas, California. I mean, I would imagine just like turning P22 into a celebrity to make a wildlife crossing happen that a video like this reinforces that this is an issue, that there should be awareness of it. And when it's solved, it's extremely adorable. Oh, wow.
还有一只山猫和她的幼崽在加利福尼亚州萨利纳斯的一座桥下兴奋地小跑。我想，就像把P-22塑造成名人来促成野生动物通道一样，像这样的视频也在强化这样一个观点：这是一个问题，人们应该对此有所意识。当问题解决时，它又是极其可爱的。哦，哇。
And so knowing these stories and seeing these videos like this, is it really changing the way people are thinking about wildlife crossings when they're doing new construction? Yeah, actually, just recently, a bill was passed in California that makes the California Department of Transportation prioritize crossings when they're working on or building new roadways. That sounds like a good thing. It is a very good thing. But the real solution would be to stop building
所以了解了这些故事并看到了这样的视频，这真的在改变人们在进行新建设时对野生动物通道的看法吗？是的，事实上，就在最近，加利福尼亚州通过了一项法案，规定加州交通局在修建或改造新道路时，必须优先考虑野生动物通道。这听起来像是一件好事。
so many damn roads in the first place so that these animals wouldn't have to cross our busy highways. That's true. This doesn't have to be a problem that we solve. It could be just a problem that we just don't create. There you go. Yeah. Well, thanks again for sharing the story with us, Roxane.
这确实是一件非常好的事。但真正的解决方法其实是停止修建这么多该死的道路，这样这些动物就根本不需要横穿我们繁忙的高速公路了。确实如此。这本不该是我们必须解决的问题。它本来可以只是一个我们压根不去制造的问题。说的就是呢。好吧，罗克桑，再次感谢你与我们分享这个故事。
We really appreciate it. Thank you, Roman. 99% Invisible was Produced This Week by Roxane Draguiti, edited by Jason Dillion and Emmett Fitzgerald. Sound mixed by Martin Gonzales, music by a directorctor sound swan rial, fact checking by gram hasha. The Laney Hall is the senior editor, Kurt Colstad is the digital director, Olivia Green is our intern. The resident includes Vivian Le, Lashemadon, Chris Barouba, Christopher Johnson, Jacob Moltenado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family.
我们非常感激。谢谢你，罗曼。“99%隐形”本周由罗克桑·德拉吉蒂（Roxane Draguiti）制作，杰森·迪利（Jason Dillon）和埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）剪辑。声音混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzales）完成，音乐由导演兼声音设计师肖恩·里尔（Swan Real）制作，事实核查由格雷厄姆·哈沙（Graham Hisha）负责。莱尼·霍尔（Laney Hoy）是高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监，奥利维亚·格林（Olivia Green）是我们的实习生。常驻人员包括维维安·勒（Vivian Le）、拉舍·马登（Lashe Madon）、克里斯·巴鲁巴（Chris Barouba）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、雅各布·莫尔特纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Moltenado Medina）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。
Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99 PI org. Run Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Forget it, Stitcher. It's Cougar Town. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在总部设在潘多拉大楼向北六个街区的地方。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（@Roman Mars）以及本节目（@99 PI org）。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜欢的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。忘了吧，Stitcher。这里是美洲狮小镇。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。